nos hemos convertido en dioses
nos hemos convertido en dioses no les
vengo a hablar de teología no les de
angular de religión les vengo a hablar
de esta capacidad creadora y la
responsabilidad que ésta nos ha traído
entonces como se los voy a platicar se
los voy a tener que practicar
evidentemente desde el punto de vista
que mejor conozco en mi experiencia yo
empecé estudiando una primera carrera de
diseño industrial
obviamente dibujaba más o menos bien y
me invitaron a trabajar en un programa
de televisión me invitaron literalmente
a diseñar las escenografías a diseñar
los gráficos y hacer pues todo lo que
tuviera que ver con cómo se montaba un
programa de televisión que era para
niños pero hace un buen buen rato
entonces me empezó a gustar empecé a
diseñar hay cosas me empezaron a llamar
para más trabajos más más cosas sobre
todo enfocados en programas infantiles
hasta que una vez tuvieron la necesidad
de un productor joven que hiciera un
programa no tan complicado pero que
supiera hablar inglés me sirve mucho el
estudiar miles toda mi vida y me
invitaron a hacer una coproducción que
se hacía con disney el programa ha
soñado a mis creo que 23 ó 24 años de
edad yo tiene que ir a grabar
cada dos meses a disney una semana en el
parque nos trataban como como reyes nos
abrían los juegos nos dejaban subirnos a
los juegos 30 veces hasta tener las
tomas
seguramente el sueño de cualquier niño
el tener esa chama y me encantaba hacer
el programa de llegábamos a mexico y
grabamos la siguiente parte que era un
estudio y empezar a darme cuenta como
los niños en ese momento recibían ese
programa en su casa prendió la
televisión y empezaban a agarrar las
cosas que nosotros hacíamos en el
programa empezaban a decir las frases
que nosotros poníamos en el programa
empezaban inclusive a vestirse a
utilizar ademanes que los conductores
utilizaban y me acuerdo que pensé
alguien está viendo lo que estamos
haciendo alguien está escuchando y
recibiendo las cosas que estamos
diciendo y de ahí me pasó una anécdota
muy muy extraña muy bizarra que saliendo
de un restaurante un día en una comida
por aire por aire polanco
estoy caminando hacia mi coche y me
agarra una señora y me dice hijo de
juega usted es el que hace el programa
de club disney de entrada que me hablan
de ustedes de edad era como raro no le
digo sí sí sí por supuesto que pasó
señor y entonces en una cajuela la
señora me pone como 40 fotos de su hija
posando en traje de baño bailando muy
extraño entonces le digo señora yo creo
que esto está mejor que lo veamos en la
oficina o en algún lugar un poco más
normal no y me acuerdo que en el coche
estaba entremedio sacado de onda de
porque me habían abordado afuera se me
ha hecho medio raro que me pusiera fotos
de su hija así en el coche y dije guau
es que es cierto el programa no lo
debemos estar haciendo con niños el
programa lo tenemos que estar haciendo
para los niños
para los niños en este momento de la
historia de mi carrera la comunicación
ha totalmente lineal la comunicación era
de aquí del estudio para afuera los
niños en su casa aprendían la televisión
y recibían lo que nosotros les estamos
dando hoy por hoy todos sabemos que la
comunicación es totalmente diferente los
paradigmas de comunicación han cambiado
si saben que pasaron 100 años de que se
inventó el teléfono a mediados del siglo
19 pasaron 100 años ex inventar el
celular pasaron 50 años ex cimentarán la
televisión y 100 años a que se inventara
el primer celular seguro muchos de
ustedes los llegaron a ver o inclusive
los llegan a utilizar en unos tabiques
enormes que de portátil tenían muy poco
pero era un celular y era un brinco de
paradigma de comunicación tremendo
porque no tienes que estar clavado en la
casa para contestar una llamada y
después qué es lo que ha pasado todos
tenemos esto esto es un poder tremendo
de creación que nos ha dado la vida o la
tecnología en este caso aquí ustedes
saben que tenemos una cámara de vídeo
una cámara fotográfica en estudio
grabación un programa de
escribir historias cualquier aplicación
le suma un aparato nuevo no seguramente
han visto de estos memes que luego ponen
en las redes de todo lo que cabe en un
iphone o en cualquier teléfono portátil
entonces la realidad es que estos
paradigmas han cambiado tremendamente
quien no ha tenido la experiencia de
tratar de explicar un abuelito como usa
redes sociales guau sana más el concepto
les rompe todo el esquema porque es otro
paradigma de comunicación y en ese
momento de mi carrera todavía la
comunicación era bastante lineal pero me
empecé a dar cuenta que había una cierta
responsabilidad de lo que estábamos
poniendo y seguir trabajando un poquito
con eso consciente en la cabeza el peso
de la palabra de lo que estábamos
haciendo mediación comunicólogo en uno
de estos procesos padrísimos para
preparar esta plática que la palabra 10
en los comunicólogos es creación social
yo sin ser comunicólogo me hizo mucho
sentido dije claro lo que ponemos en el
programa es lo que los niños están
haciendo si nosotros ponemos que hay que
brincar los niños esperamos brinquen en
su casa pero si les ponemos alguna cosa
negativa pues probablemente lo van a
hacer
aunque queramos o no lo queramos y
entonces en el siguiente punto en el
siguiente momento de mi carrera lo que
traté de hacer es trabajar con eso
conscientemente no me tocó por ejemplo
producir un programa que se llamaba el
jugo una luz donde lo que tratábamos era
que los niños se divertirán de la manera
más sana blanca y divertida posible y
después me dieron que hiciera un
programa donde la la marca patrocinadora
era una marca de dulces entonces también
tenía un poquito este reto de cómo hacer
un programa positivo cuando pues es un
programa de dulces y no necesariamente
puro dulces bueno ya saben todas estas
discusiones que existen y lo que
acabamos haciendo es trabajar una cosa
muy interesante con el patrocinador y
que a la larga le funcionó y le encantó
hicimos un programa de actividad física
un programa de actividad física
patrocinado por dulces teníamos
conciencia de que lo que estábamos
enseñando tenía un resultado o una
injerencia en lo que iban a hacer los
niños después tuve la maravillosa
oportunidad de que me invitarán a
participar haciendo plaza sésamo y se
plaza sésamo con 19 años como seis
temporadas aquí en méxico para toda
latinoamérica y una cosa interesantísima
que aprendí de ellos es que hay una
metodología
extraordinariamente puntual y específica
para que los contenidos del programa
realmente funcionarán para lo que
queríamos que funcionara que era para
darle ciertas herramientas a los niños
en edad preescolar que aprendieran cosas
positivas entonces si bien es el
programa tenía evidentemente un punto de
vista muchísimo más educativo reforzaba
mucho esto que yo traía en la cabeza
vamos a hacer un programa divertido por
supuesto plaza sésamo pese a que mi
hermana me hacía verlo así no es nada
más de aprender a las letras y cerca y
lejos sino también es de divertirte y
echar relajo y que los niños se
diviertan con los muppets pero ustedes
no sabrán que hasta la última palabra
que dicen estos monstruos está cuidada
para que sea una cosa positiva para los
niños y por último eso me llevó por
fortuna a participar en este maravilloso
proyecto que es el teletón 21 años llevo
haciéndolo con todo cariño porque es
estos proyectos que realmente tienes la
posibilidad de ver bien concreto el
resultado de lo que estás diciendo
haciendo produciendo y mandando hacia
allá pero qué es lo que está pasando
ahorita
todo todo si está entremezclando
ya las la comunicación no sale de aquí
para allá ya no solamente es como en
este momento que les decía del programa
de disney donde yo producir el programa
lo grababa y yo salía para allá y el
niño en su casa lo prendía y recibe a lo
que yo le daba hoy por hoy para nada
el paradigma de comunicación que tenemos
hoy es que todo el mundo le contesta a
todo el mundo la comunicación sale de
todo el mundo y sobre todo todos somos
creadores todos podemos tener el poder
de la creación en este aparatito que les
enseñaba todos podemos tener poder de la
creación todos podemos poner nuestra
palabra y palabra con todo esto que yo
aprendí en los programas infantiles
palabra es igual la acción una palabra
es igual a acción qué es lo que pasa
ustedes seguramente han visto estas
cosas que pasa en las redes sociales
donde se empiezan a poner cosas de moda
y luego hay unas consecuencias
impresionantes había un caso de unas
niñas en un país extranjero que se
metieron en todo un rollo de un
personaje que se llamaba slender man y
las chavitas se emocionaron tanto con el
personaje que acabaron haciendo una cosa
horrible asesinaron una compañía
por resultado de cosas que ven en redes
sociales otras cosas que pasan por
ejemplo seguramente le lleno en este
caso donde una de las chavas kardashian
que las siguen muchas personas en las
redes sociales un día se le ocurrió
decir
la nueva interfase de snap chat no me
gusta un snap se pierde un gran
porcentaje de valor en las redes
sociales nada más por ese tweet porque
la chava tiene 100 millones de
seguidores y obviamente tiene mucha
injerencia no o la cantidad de
movimientos sociales que sabemos que en
la política se han generado este y los
movimientos árabes ciertas revoluciones
ya las redes nos comunican a todos y por
supuesto que se pueden utilizar para
bien también hemos visto muchísimas
muchísimos ejemplos en las redes donde
una familia necesita apoyo de alguna
manera y toda la comunidad hasta de
gente que no los conoce empieza a
utilizar las redes para sumarse lo vimos
inclusive con lo que pasó en el país el
año pasado todo tiene un poder de
creación y un poder de destrucción pero
ese poder es impresionante como se está
generando
ustedes saben por ejemplo que se suben
300 horas de vídeo a youtube por minuto
por minuto se suben 300 horas de vídeo a
youtube por día se mandan 500 millones
de tweets 500 millones de mensajes por
día imagínense todo lo que nos estamos
rebotando de contenido ya el contenido
no es como yo lo aprendí de aquí para
allá y el contenido no es que tú te
sientes en tu tele y te pones a ver un
programa un documental una película y
ahorita te pones a ver ese documental y
empiezas a opinar sobre el documental
ves una película y empiezas a criticar
al actor todos ya saben que nos volvemos
directores técnicos cómo juega la
selección y productores cuando vemos a
una película pero pero todo todo este
tipo de comunicación que es lo que pasa
que tiene ingerencia aunque no quieras
palabra es acción tengo varios amigos
actores por ejemplo que ya está tienen
miedo de poner cosas en sus redes
sociales porque ya no saben que les van
a contestar ponen una opinión personal y
bueno les escriben hasta lo que se va a
morir su perro los cachorros de su perro
y los cachorros que ni siquiera tuvieron
los cachorros del perro
entonces qué es lo que pasa que los
actores ya no ponen nada hay una acción
concreta el actor te dice híjole javi
aunque me gustaría opinar sobre esto y
apoyarte en esto me da miedo me da miedo
lo que vayan a poner por supuesto qué
palabra es igual de acción hay una
persona o varias personas en algún otro
lugar que ni siquiera conoce el actor ni
siquiera sabe cuáles son sus
motivaciones ni siquiera sabe si es
buena onda mala onda pero como opina y
opina tan vitro nicamente el actor tiene
una acción que es poner o no poner
y eso es algo que es bien importante
tener en mente todos los mensajes tienen
una consecuencia se anticipada o no
anticipada les aseguro que quien empezó
a poner estos estos rollos de la
mitología les lenderman jamás imaginó
que unas chavitas en su ignorancia de
juvenil pues lo iban a utilizar para
hacer la espantos edad que hicieron pero
todos los mensajes tienen consecuencias
la pensemos o no la pensemos el otro día
fui a la escuela de mi hijo y me acuerdo
que vi un póster que me llamó muchísimo
la atención porque mi hijo tiene 12 años
y está empezando a meterse en este mundo
de las redes sociales y de iu de que sus
compañeros tienen un teléfono entonces
que quiere también el tener su teléfono
nosotros hemos tratado evidentemente de
ser muy cuidadoso con eso porque además
como se dan cuenta tengo una opinión muy
fuerte personal sobre eso pero me
acuerdo que había un póster que me llamó
muchísimo la atención y el póster decía
más o menos no palabras más palabras
menos ahora que vas a empezar a meterte
en las redes sociales antes de que poste
es algo piensa en tres cosas la primera
cosa realmente estás seguro de lo que
quiere es postear
y esa es una pregunta que esta zona
tonta pero es muy cierto cuántas veces
lo hemos dicho cosas sin pensar y
tenemos reacciones sin pensar los que
tenemos esposas cuando te preguntan mi
amor cómo me veo nunca contestes a la
primera
tienes que pensarlo antes entonces
cuando posteas algo en las redes
sociales es como si contestará sillas ya
está entonces evidentemente lo primero
que tienes que hacer estás seguro de lo
que quiere es postear lo segundo me
llamó muchísimo la atención estás seguro
que no estás afectando a nadie
y me acuerdo que tenía muchísimas otras
palabras y muchísimas otras
explicaciones pero es muy cierto cuando
tú posteas algo igual y sale una amiga
tuya atrás así en la foto que tú muy
emocionado te tomaste the selfish y tu
amiga atrás estaba estás este
estornudando la típica foto que te
agarran a la mitad del estornudo y sales
horrible esa foto evidentemente le va a
afectar esa amiga está seguro de lo que
está a punto de posteando y que no va a
afectar a nadie no si la va a afectar a
ella también puede parecer muy chistoso
que la agarre a medias tornú dicom y
mocasín volando pero seguramente ya no
seguramente ya se va a sentir vulnerada
etc y eso sin hablar de muchas otras
cosas de contenido que pueden afectar a
alguien más quieras o no que eso es bien
importante
afectas a alguien quieras o no hay que
pensarlo antes de postear y el tercero
es drastik y ximo antes la comunicación
lineal tú mandas un mensaje y el mensaje
en general tu ya se perdía inclusive hay
programas que yo mismo y si no estoy tan
viejo que ya ni siquiera existe porque
el cassette ya se perdió ya se borró ya
o sea son mensajes que se perdían y hoy
por hoy todo es permanente
hoy por hoy tú subes algo en las redes
sociales y aunque los bordes de tu
timeline alguien 18 años después como
está pasando ahorita en los movimientos
políticos lo recupera y te pone el
recuerdo de lo que dijiste lo que
subiste lo que pusiste entonces como no
vas a estar seguro de algo que va a
quedar para toda la eternidad y que te
lo van a poder buscar lo que ya me
platicaba alguien que se encarga de
reclutar gente muchas veces hasta
revisan tu historial de redes sociales
para ver cómo eres no una cosa es cómo
te presentas y otra cosa es lo que
apuntas entonces me acuerdo que esas
tres cosas en el póster me llama
muchísimo la atención
hay que ser responsables de lo que
ponemos el poder de nuestra palabra
estamos seguros de lo que queremos poner
estamos seguros de que a nadie afectamos
estamos seguros de que vamos a estar de
acuerdo con que eso viva para siempre en
las redes sociales
yo conscientemente en mi trabajo abrace
esa responsabilidad abrace esa
responsabilidad de darme cuenta que
palabra es igual a acción
ahora es igual a acción quieras o no lo
que dices tú tiene una consecuencia
quieras o no abrace esa responsabilidad
y trato que aunque yo hago televisión
entretenimiento generalmente por lo
menos tengamos un punto que sabes que
dejas algo positivo o que tratemos de no
dejar cosas negativas
y hay que hacerlo así porque eso es en
lo que realmente creemos y en lo que y
en lo que tenemos que considerar que ese
poder que se nos puso
es la mejor manera de utilizarlo por eso
los invito a que pensemos esto como en
buenas mitologías hay dioses buenos y
dioses malos hay dioses creadores y
dioses destructores con este poder que
los medios de comunicación hoy en día
nos han dado a todos nosotros todos nos
hemos convertido en dioses de crear
cosas todos tenemos la posibilidad de
subir una foto subir un vídeo subieron
una opinión subir una palabra y eso
tiene consecuencias que dios qué tipo de
dios queremos ser
queremos ser dioses creadores o queremos
ser dioses destructores queremos que
nuestra palabra sirva poca para
construir o queremos que nuestra palabra
sirva para destruir yo no sé ustedes
pero yo tomé la decisión y creo que vale
la pena hacerlo así seguramente se
acordarán de esta película de
superhéroes que hace poquito salió donde
nuestros superiores spider-man pues
empieza a darse cuenta que tiene unos
mega poderes y su abuelo y su tío ven le
dice una frase bien bien dura le dice
con cualquier gran poder
en responsabilidad si tenemos ese poder
de creación estamos dispuestos a
aceptarla con responsabilidad yo los
invito a que sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]